hey everybody welcome to another episode
of erisa fury i'm kelsey cook and i was
so stoked today to be joined by the one
and only Freddie Prinze jr. you might
know him from she's all that I know what
you did last summer right scooby-doo
it's right down to you you that's a
random one okay I was a 13 year old girl
at one point okay a [ __ ] dream and
people might also know you from your
podcast prints in the wolf yeah what
comedian Josh wolf
a victim of your show yes yet another
it's weird there's so many victims so
few champions yeah it's a weird show I
don't know how you're gonna you're gonna
have to have a lot of friends cuz I
don't know how many repeat victims
you're gonna get I love that you you
texted me after writing you're like yeah
I'm gonna start like what do you say
like a skeeball show or just some other
like shitty I'm gonna start a horrible
show it's just gonna be called sucks to
be Kelsey and you're just gonna have to
do horrible say it's gonna be one long
episode of you recreating all the
humiliations that you made everyone else
do and then at the end it's going to
turn into a vehicle for Kelsey Grammer
and you're out that's how that's how
excited I am I'm really happy to have
you tell me your first ball experience
I'm like a little bit a little bit I
played in middle school there was this
dude his name was Jason Grossman and
they had a table at their house and he
was sick he would just crush everybody
he was like like Seth Green is that good
at ping-pong that's how good this dude
was at foosball he would just smash on
everybody okay and then I kissed his
sister so we were friends anymore
so then I didn't get to play again until
high school in 1990 and I played like a
little bit for my freshman year that
sucks yeah senior year really like I got
like four years of experience there
20-some odd years ago but I played D&D
and karate and video games
this wasn't your jam no I was rolling
dice but I'm good at games okay oh I'm
come
child so I'm not that competitive
because your mom's like oh you win you
know yeah you're just throwing a ball
against the wall but in like martial
arts you definitely didn't want to lose
because it hurt so I'm somewhat
competitive and there's spikes here
coming towards me so I feel like I can
summon some of the spirit and I've seen
the side-to-side moves I've seen your
little bounce bounce moves where I could
do the drill well let's see five seconds
but uh well yeah I can do it I'm so
excited so your podcast co-host and
friend Josh wolf was unfortunately he's
a very sweet man but one of the worst
players Dave had on the show do you feel
like you're gonna do better than Josh
Josh well he said a low bars it's really
I don't feel like I'm saying bad things
against the man to go yeah because that
bar was low I will say this you know he
enjoys his edibles I know he probably
was on ten of them and that slows the
man down it slows the man down
I know uh heart of a foosball champion
it's not discernible skill coordination
yeah like we does not we just had Dan
Soder on who also is a big fan of weed
and it's like it's not the best for
foosball no it's way better for Netflix
absolutely and not good for sports
although like I know jiu-jitsu guys
that'll get high before they roll and
they're like it just helps me flow like
yeah alright and then I'm tapping out
and I'm like wow okay so you flow so
maybe there maybe there's something yeah
I feel like it would delay your reaction
which like with that and with first ball
you need to be you know like well I've
been taking steroids for three days
straight my head's growing like like
Barry Bonds I'm telling you by the time
we're like three points in I'm gonna be
three times bigger I'm so okay so we're
gonna play the first round just a
standard game two five okay so far like
five yeah so the Warriors nabel's they
put ten for like over time but you
always just play to five well just kind
of you know see how it goes see how it
goes all right offense defense
probably both after that we'll do some
some things to make it a little bit
easier for you to beat me think like you
leave and Josh come sit
okay attack and I just thing I say I
take it back is a great show
[Music]
I get the ball first you get the ball
first time I'll let you have the ball
first all right and I have I make two
touches before the game can even start
yeah man that's like instant pressure
but okay it just prevents people from
like whacking it and then do I say hey
are you ready after the dribble or are
you just ready cuz you're pro I'm ready
but you have to ask to stock the dollar
are you sick in a dog on me like while
I'm playing but you were the one that
gets handicapped you reacted like a dog
like you I had thought I heard a dog and
literally like oh my god there are dogs
here so you are you heard one but that
is not involved in any punishment for
distraction okay
all right so you just say you ready I
say ready and then you dribble and go
alright ready ready alright I'm asking
myself you pointed at you ready yes
control out the gate that's great
I remember this game crazy it makes it
is I need to be jumping around flipping
paddles I got you take stuff out your
pockets before to be like aerodynamic I
felt like just slow ok now it's your
ball so it goes back to you so whoever
scores last you yeah I got the dribble
part and this is up yeah so you're just
gonna go for this score you're not gonna
try and pass oh yeah yeah why did I pass
to you laughs stuff wow it's hard okay
five are is I think like a hardest rod
to learn because there's so many tiny
little movements in so many ways they
can get [ __ ] up this one seems harder
a goalie that has one bar this one's
easier what are you talking about this
is harder think about how you keep just
like hitting it to me there's so many
little angles that you can miss heads
over replay the shots she just did and
explained to her with like graphics and
stuff why that was way easier
do you not see what you did it looked
like a tic-tac like the orange flavored
tic-tac it went so fast is telling me
but but this one's harder there's only
one I got is the dribble oh it's hard to
pass
you got your points oh god yes holy [ __ ]
really hard I have to be ready for
anything
whoa that's what happens when he's like
a little dead zones and you know do you
play no spinning no spins ease down to
play knows Benzies awesome Oh flip them
I saw the little clip burn more doesn't
make you feel like you were close
no not a clean clean shot I haven't even
gotten it past the line like there's a
lot of cussing in this game very nice I
said they're actually do you know that
there are referees at tournaments can
you curse in front of the rep you can
curse but you can't get curse out of the
rest like imagine you can't you can't
curse out your opponent you can't a jar
which is like if you are playing defense
too aggressively and you move the ball
that's a penalty why are you looking for
angles what's what was this I had to see
I'd like it's enough reo and law and
order like what folks in holes I felt
like maybe I could go between but you
got pretty good did you did you wait
exactly between exactly what you wanted
to do that's weird
you can just do that slightly your
parents play too right
that's how they met my parents met
playing on a professional foosball
tournament so I wouldn't exist if I won
I can't talk trash because I played
Dungeons & Dragons but yeah that's its
that's at my level of nerd even right no
it's cool because it he said to them is
that sad to them I don't have no shame I
played D&D I'm 43 years old teach them
first ball DD stuff like that like are
they little mini nerds
my daughter's ten so she's old enough to
understand games and deal with losing ah
we're gonna do that I was ten times
slower um but she hasn't run a game yet
so I'm about to be a dungeon master for
her and three of her friends and kind of
show them the ropes but she's a great
storyteller okay so even though her
teachers don't always think so
yo her teacher my daughter comes over in
school is that five already yeah I won
so my daughter comes home
yeah that's great and she uh she goes
bad I wrote this amazing story can I
tell you I go yeah tell me your story
she goes it's it's kind of sad I go
that's alright and my daughter's very
like Tim Burton II like Victoria Rice
like she likes dark horrible stuff okay
or Anne Rice insipid courage but Andrew
yes yeah like like the little girl so
she goes alright you're the lead in it I
go thank you she goes in your you're the
Prince but someone kills your mom and
I'm like well that is said then your
grandfather sends you on this journey
all around the world I don't know what
world it is not this world that but it's
going to be a world from
another dimension I'm like alright it's
a world so she goes but as soon as you
get to the farthest end of it you
realize it was your grandfather who
killed your mother so he could be king
again I don't want you 10 yeah and I'm
like damn that's deep I go that's that
she goes you have to go back and he goes
on this like voyage every year where
they do this like fishing thing cuz it's
a fisherman's village and you have a
sword fight on the boat and you cut off
his head and you're the king and I'm
like dad steeps cuz yeah my teacher
won't let me ride it just walked out of
the room I was like what I'm gonna be
talking to your teacher tomorrow and so
I had that door to have a conversation
like you couldn't give her a note like
say maybe put the grandpa in jail I'm
like why he just stunned her creativity
I'm like so she's dark whatever man you
made it think it was crap I thought the
story was sick and she's like no I
didn't mean that
it's just they have to read it to the
kindergarten class and I was like Oh
what did you tell her that and she goes
I don't think she knew it I'll say oh
yeah the greatest video to wash a
ten-year-old read that story to just
horrified the good officer that's my
grandpa yeah so that's my daughter I
named Charlotte and she's awesome
oh sweet sweet emotion
[Music]
now what you think I was sandbagging but
let's just say a thousand again oh [ __ ]
are you know I was coached by a world
champion Mike Smith you know Mike
Johnson I call him Big Mike actually the
little blast name you've heard a big all
right
you lying red blanket okay what never
you okay Bryan what's the pretty sure
that's Josh wolf plays for you number
one just one person yeah I think so
Bryan what's the number one advantage oh
that's zero advantage so it'll be five
to three when the game is the greatest
show ever I have to play in handcuffs
you're still gonna win but it you should
have to play like that that would be
even better and on one foot what a
pirate eye patch and you're getting a
root canal
you know I will play behind my back oh
look that's so gangster that is uh
seriously I'll give you so much do it do
it I mean why not gonna win you're sick
I'm sorry
well had one good hit I've lost in the
middle around a few times now because we
do make it to but then you play it legit
right what rock did everybody just watch
me to do that so but hey let's take it
back you're not Vincent D'Onofrio from
criminal intent he was never screw that
up by the end I'm gonna have [ __ ]
scoliosis it's like I this for my wife's
back for real is like oh my god the
switcher says I think it's just more to
give me a rubber bag every night she's
like oh it hurts so bad today I'm like
that's weird it hurts so bad
every night your man's smarter than me
alright so we're gonna play another game
to five but you guys start with three
points so take your three points oh
that's even better all right [ __ ]
alright D'Onofrio
are you ready what's his name detective
Gorham that's you detective Gorham this
is so insane cuz you're good it's so
weird such a mindfuck because you're
going in knowing
gonna get whooped and then you're
sitting there like this I'm like well I
got a shot and then the other part of
your brains like not you are like
Chrissy seven years ago Chris yes okay -
she still blocked the first one she
still blocked the first one
come on give me that ball I did not get
a coach named Mike Johnson that was all
hook it just was random and not a
spinner
not a spinner no coach that was luck I
swear all I did was go
you heard me scream that was luck but it
makes me feel good this was a terrible
idea but it makes me feel good this is
way way too much advantage for you and
way too much disadvantage Elsie I drove
from the Palisades to Burbank I deserve
this I need the ball I don't know you
know I'm like legit adrenaline shaking
right now is like riding go-karts when
you're ten I have to bank it I think oh
I was a spinner that should be your ball
that is a spinner I think you really
yeah okay okay so put on five bars there
we go it's [ __ ] man
you're just a lot of integrity all right
play it straight man especially when
you're headed back to me on the back guy
yeah dude mm-hmm all right ready ready
ready ready I hope I'm a doing can I do
this I'm gonna do this Kocher hmm
so deep oh my god I'm having a heart
attack
y'all having a regular Arbeit take it
easy no for real
this is like my normal speed and this is
so slow motion for you and I'm like wow
that's fast can you set it back I'm late
guy you get it again yeah got a sweet
steal you score the last but I had a
sweet steal no that's Jesus don't do
realize that okay so I get it back again
oh I hate that you keep getting it okay
are you gonna have a foosball injury is
this a SAG showed you this non-union our
YouTube web series you're in trouble so
you mentioned your wife you're married
to Sarah Michelle Gellar yeah that's
right we've been married a long time
living together almost 18 years that is
amazing you are one of the longest
married couples in Hollywood yeah in
America problem in a minute
Oh Laureus I hate it but that was
amazing I deceive one point one point
god I hope I can come back in time I
hope that makes it simmer I hope it
makes you nervous
it doesn't make me nervous I get the
ball now right mm-hmm
all right get you your pieces where you
want them yes okay okay all right you
ready yep
one two okay no there's no good way to
do this just waiting for it to happen is
brutal so I got married a couple months
ago oh you are married now I knew you
were engaged congratulations
where'd you guys get married at down in
La Jolla and he's Canadian to you do you
have like what are your prettier
marriage tips that's cuz that's
incredible to last that long and I think
also as like a couple in the industry
right yeah I think so I mean marriage in
general is tough right like Sarah and I
are best friends but we we argue she
pisses me off yeah I piss her off
yeah and it took us about 15 years to go
oh these are the things that don't
change these are the things that do
change okay I better be okay with these
things
yeah well that's a wrap yeah and so once
we had that kind of a conversation and
it was and this happened as our
relationship grew it wasn't like just oh
well before we get married let's make
sure you know cuz nobody does that like
now and if they say they dude they're
full of it we didn't know we're just
young pretty and in love so that's how
it happened so we learned as we went and
I don't try to change her girl things
that make me crazy and she doesn't
change my guy things that make her nuts
yeah she was never like that yeah
because it's between when it's back here
then it goes back room I'm going online
as soon as this is over going online as
soon as this is over the first forum so
that and we make each other laugh like
we give each other of our time and in a
good way
yeah we believe in each other's success
she doesn't believe in me in this game
but I just got the handicap victory note
that I put the Astor's handicap before I
just said victory sorry yo you were
that'd be like and behind my back I mean
well Mazda Vidale could probably knock a
dude out even with his hands behind his
back but it's pretty close damn it
well now you get to take out all your
aggression and just oh it's kind of
[Music]
now we're gonna play two ball which is
where we each start with a ball come on
at the same time the same time we go one
two three go
we both hit it and you have to score
both balls to get one point if we each
score when it's a wash this is House
Rules this can't be real
no this is a real event this happened
that actual tournament there's a trophy
for two ball there's a two ball trophy
is it one of those a two ball trophy the
shocker two ball two ball
this is winner takes all right now we're
tied which is we're not like we're not
we're not
you were easy would be for me to beat up
my seven-year-old son but I don't I
literally go take your best shot and my
hands are behind my back and he'll still
knock himself out all right like this I
know what's going on here I'm a dad Oh
so some winner takes all here's the
thing this is brutal
if you lose yeah youyou told me
beforehand no doctor eats which I
respect
I respect me no dog treats family dog
biscuit just not that wet food okay no
movie don't have what food we just had
no puns but here's the thing I asked
Josh wolf oh you asked Josh so he's
gonna give you the worst possible like
if you still hold on if you say the word
I'm gonna throw up
does the word start with em if it's I'm
gonna throw up all over the table don't
even say the word you don't know oh my
god don't say the word for I won't gotta
answer the question my eyes are watering
up yo I will most fired someone on my
sitcom like 15 years ago cuz they
thought it was funny and they put it in
there for me to grin up yeah I was legit
mad if the guy was like and he was my
man and I was like Donovan what's the
matter Joe I was like I was so hot I was
so hot and it was on my finger and I
could smell it this is horrible
just know this is going
be the last time you probably spoke to
Josh wolf a killer well no but I'm gonna
whip his ass and he's not he's gonna
know if he talks to you again i'ma whip
his ass again he can't fight I watch the
Sun beat him up we're not in it so all
right
at first I was like let's make him take
like a little shot of mayonnaise I
thought I produce it away that's too
mean who's want you to know that's for
my heart with that Oh dad we're gonna
put young get a stand-up comic to do
that right you get a skateboarder to do
that it's gonna be a lot harder to get
actors or a rock star forget about it a
rock star be like no you can feed it to
that guy I'll watch and play bass like
this is not gonna happen
we're just gonna put a little bit on a
piece of bread and you just take a bite
oh oh
actually this is gonna make it might be
worth to miss when I was a kid
my favorite snack was it don't sit just
Wonder Bread with mayo
that's how trash I yeah that's pretty
trashed by the way it's pretty trash and
I did some trash moves but that I'm the
product that's baseball that's what
happens man a Oh bread no I think I can
handle just don't do with other
syllables you know what I mean oh just
don't finish it Mayo
we'll just do ya like that basketball
player and I'll think about that if you
lose that's what they lose
why do you say if you lose is that what
you say to everyone so if you want you
just say so here's what's gonna happen
I'm gonna humiliate you in this and then
after this I'm gonna humiliate you again
and then after that you want to be
humiliated on the 134 and a 405 stuck in
traffic
it's a trip why don't you just say it
like that well because you'd have no
guest I want to try and be a little nice
I know that it's kind of happening you
know it's by all aware but I'm gonna
give it a damn good
it's gonna be a fun journey to get to
the to the Mayo without saying the rest
of the word
alright so job oh oh that this sucks for
Kelsey show is gonna be so good
it's gonna be such I'm telling you it's
gonna have a million views my first day
that this sucks for Kelsey show is gonna
be on NBC it's gonna be on god they're
coming you could get every guest I've
had on here who's like yeah I'm in like
I'm drunker Oh Josh I bet Josh would be
done yes that's right except Josh rest
in peace okay so give me one more box
yep and so then we place it where you
want to place it and you don't even know
a dribble oh okay it's just one two
three go okay ready what hold on I'm not
ready hold the height you are you're so
mad you lost a game where you played
like this who cares
you lost William backwards I can't I
can't lose I hate and be like Carl
always losing a race running backwards
to a little kitty price to be hot about
all right no I'm doing the Kelsie cook
yes right there I see that line you got
wait okay that doesn't count this [ __ ]
don't count okay making because I rarely
cuz I love it is just head on with you
and then just see what happens see how
you like that [ __ ] and just game
road-blocking okay it's a technical term
I coach Mike do the roadblocks how I
beat her in 2008 yeah that's right I met
Mike nice to three go you legit gave me
an injury okay wait it's a wash cuz I
scored 110 you scored one so nobody so
nobody gets a point
oh that's right two to get one [ __ ] I
got to ice up my god goddammit that's
why you poked them out a little yeah I
put the toes out
hashtag toes up and like that you score
those a nice shot I gotta get to I gotta
get oh come on I'm not allowed to cuss
you out you said you're not allowed 13
year old me that's some day Freddie
Prinze jr. would say [ __ ] you dummy I
would my brain would explode 1 2 3 go
yeah watched it was an observer like a
like a like a Cleveland Cavalier when
LeBron won the championships watching so
of all of all the rom-coms you've done
what was your what was your favorite to
do uh the one with Rachel she's all that
she's all that yeah everybody's favorite
she uh Rachel and I are still friends to
this day we both have kids yeah they
would both always kind of looked alike
she was more like a sister than yeah
like a love interest even more making
the movie like it was never any weird
tension yeah and that was rare she most
of the time there's something even if
nothing happens there's something but
with Rachel I was just cool from day one
and and we had already worked together
let's do this okay we had already worked
together on a little independent movie
called the house of yes the movie was at
Sundance okay and do I get the bollard
you get this line yeah the movie was at
Sundance and I brought my girlfriend
there and they looked a lot alike okay
and we were all staying in the same
house at Sundance for our movie okay and
I saw my girlfriend standing there in
her towel because she gotten out of the
hot tub and I went and gave her a hug
and it was Rachel and I was like oh my
god and she laughed so hard and so she
kind of always held that over me and I
was before she's all that even happened
so we already had a good relationship
and we were chilled that's amazing
but I just had good experiences on that
you know I was like yeah like Paul was
on that Paul Walker rest in peace he was
a big Jitsu buddy of mine oh wow I just
washed you I said Paul Walker you got
misty-eyed you were like oh dear Lord
gold that's all it takes they should
have been dropping that name sooner I
want to talk about the movies he was
shirtless dude good lord I'll smoke you
to rest at his game damn it focus Kelsey
I remember he came in to audition yeah
and we were already buddies okay and I
knew he was gonna get it because the
producers were like yeah so uh I ran
outside yeah you can't see it so I ran
outside real quick and I was like hey
man you're gonna get you they're gonna
tell you not strong enough they're gonna
tell you they only have 30 grand for the
role but they got 50 so make sure you
get all 50 names like bro thanks I was
like I got you and I ran back kids acted
like I just washed my hands I was like
all right who's next who's next they
probably should have been better friends
but we did that nonsense you do where
you're like I'll see you in two weeks
you can just put it off a million times
and yeah one day you're like ah [ __ ] Wow
so learn from that's a great story
that's a great [ __ ] story yeah all
right one two three go
[Applause]
neither of a score I can't get past your
front damn line Oh too slow too slow and
you so you did she's all that and then
you did I know what you did last summer
after that no I know you did was the
first thing I got noticed for that was
not really okay that was a Sarah yeah we
met on that we were just bros she
couldn't drive she was from New York and
we had to drive like an hour to get to
the gym and she would go to the gym and
I would surf and I would pick her up and
her but we were just friends like we
didn't get along at all I had a
girlfriend over here I was born in LA on
a surfboard she's born and raised Jewish
girl from New York yeah it literally was
like yeah I'll Drive so it wasn't one of
those like 1 2 3 go
so it wasn't one of those like love at
first sight you can at least start
dating we were friends at first time
okay yeah we were just good friends I
didn't think she ate enough
she was a young actor in the 90s yeah so
me and my cousins would all go over and
cook for her and her mom we were just
really tight and then one day we went on
a date I'm not a date but we were gonna
go out with our publicist into town stop
to you boys
almost
male that's cool that you're at least
selling the word nice I'll be doing this
whole thing it will not be cleanable
well then I'm blocking you so deal with
that alright one two three go now the
soul both times my poor goalie just got
murdered murdered murder
I'll give you your fifth point um that's
brood this guy first of all you're cut
cut if we play again legit amount of
problems with that guy you're like not
happy with him
you always make everyone play the black
set just for production we usually put
our guests over there but we've the
table come on
like weigh this down with lead and this
will be blacked out like a wily coyote
fake tunnel in the wall so it'll look
real but you'll be like this son of a
[ __ ] is blocking everything I'll be
like they call me the wall you have my
name show that's part of what's the show
Kelsey is gonna hate sucks for Kelsey
that's great that's a great rewrite you
can be a writer on the soon-to-be Kelsey
Grammer show thank you so much um I'm
not looking forward to this I don't even
know if I can look at it I may just have
to like go there's a real nice glob glob
I can deal with the lob of man it's a
one syllable word I can deal with it
okay just a bite just debate being nice
just a bite oh you doubled it up man if
you doubled it up with your big-ass
pirate beard you doubled it up I respect
beards I got a beard on my pirate and
see if these and you're just off he's
kind of did you toast the bread you
toasted the bread why watch at what did
you put the effort into toasting so nice
that is so nice what would you toast it
oh this is gonna be a Brit no stay close
might turn into a double humiliation
real quick and a lot of comics out there
would all at the same time scream
justice here we go you ready to go down
I can't even buy it it's not even real
bread is this mm-hmm
you got it mmm you got it it's mostly
bread it's mostly bread there's a little
bit of something in there oh it's so
sour but not in like a mmm mmm you've
got to make your brain do it I know
everything somebody hate mayo I can't
swallow it there's no way you got it the
what you've already chewed it some carbs
just replenish you after this defeat the
breads not an issue Kelsey I don't care
about the carbs it's yeah we got water
on hand
okay I'm gonna swallow I'm gonna swallow
this is the worst show this is the worst
show [ __ ] you that's what that's done
that's done gotta give us something
better than water man I got a list arena
guys gonna have like antibiotics or
something okay I smell it I can smell it
oh my god you can't smell it no I just
know bread bread why did you toast the
bread it made it so much harder to eat
that's a double ganger so not only not
only will it taste shitty we're gonna
make it take longer than normal bike and
be warm oh don't say what
I call it definitely war yeah I don't
even want to think about that I'm so mad
I came here which is all the best
Congrats on your marriage oh I wish it
nothing but awesomeness it's really cool
to see a couple just like killing it I
think you guys are gonna kill it cuz all
the stuff that would make your man leave
you you just do two dudes on the [ __ ]
yeah you're like by the way seven course
meal spent six hours doing it like it
was nothing
oh yeah please always listen or watch
Josh waltz on my podcast Prince on the
wolf it his last one will be this week
and then he won't be joining me anymore
because he made me do your show and
he'll be well just hospitalized I won't
kill the man he's got kids but also on
my youtube channel its gag head its egg
head with a G or you can watch it on
Twitch same thing egghead egghead with a
G and we do a lot of tabletop
role-playing games still to this day um
I do a lot of like regular board games
of comics you should come do one we've
done the Oregon Trail everyone dies
we'll get dysentery it's super cool and
it's just like the computer game only
with car it's super fun so come do it
and if you like that [ __ ] then check out
Instagram at Kelsey Creek comedy Kelsey
cook calm for tour dates please
subscribe to the all things comedy
YouTube channel watch the other episodes
watch Josh Wolf's episode and by erisa
fury shirt we'll see you guys next time
thank you guys for watching another
episode of erisa fury be sure to pick up
your official Larisa fury shirts if they
are buttery soft they feel like dolphin
skin they're lovely be sure to LIKE and
subscribe to the all things comedy
channel and you can get the shirts at
the link below
free shipping
[Music]
you